when you and Melissa were in bridesmaids
together you did some pretty racy stuff
and I occurred to me you have kids
obviously probably too young to have
seen bridesmaids but eventually they're
gonna see you with her doing this
comically absurd sexual stuff right
unless of course the movie just kind of
fades out of you no not gonna happen
never get horrified and I'm you know
melissa is terrified we are convinced
they're gonna swear off sandwiches yeah
I think I think we have that moment here
as a picture of you where you're yeah
what do you do what do you say to your
mean I have that problem I've done I've
done hundreds of thousands of shockingly
embarrassing things over the years and I
just assumed that there's so much of it
that my kids will never see I'll just
won't see it but that movie they're
gonna see yeah you know I I'm just gonna
build a House of Lies as early as I can
I'm gonna add to it brick by brick
you're a good dad right yeah you're a
very good dad build a house of laws
you